The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on non-linear finite
element analysis.
The title of this lecture is
"Basic Considerations in
Non-Linear Analysis." In this
lecture I would like to
discuss with you first the
application of the principle
of virtual work.
We will spend quite a bit of
time on the basic principle of
virtual work, because it's such
an important ingredient
for non-linear finite
element analysis.
In fact, the displacement-based
finite
element method, which is widely
used for non-linear
analysis, is based on an
application of the principle
of virtual work.
I also would like to discuss
with you and particularly
emphasize some basic
requirements of mechanics.
There are a few very important
requirements of mechanics that
it is important to always keep
in mind, and I'd like to share
some experiences with you
regarding these requirements.
And finally, to emphasize all
the points that I have tried
to make in the lecture, I like
to present and share with you
some experiences regarding
some actual analyses.
And I've chosen two analyses.
First we will look at the
analysis of a plate with a
hole, and then we will look
at the analysis of a
plate with a crack.
Let me now go over to my view
graph and start with a
discussion of the principle
of virtual work.
The principle of virtual work,
in essence, says that this
integral here on the left-hand
side is equal to what is on
the right-hand side.
And we should, of course,
discuss now in detail what we
have on the left- and on
the right-hand side.
On the right-hand side,
we have this tR--
this is a script R, an unusual
symbol, but some time ago,
some long time ago, I decided
to select this
symbol for this quantity.
This script t, superscript t
R, contains two integrals.
The first integral is an
integral over the volume tv.
Notice it's the current volume
of the body of tfiB, the body
forces at time t multiplied
by the virtual
displacement, del ui.
This product here is
integrated over the
volume at time t.
We add to this integral another
integral, which is an
integral over the surface
area of the body.
And here we have surface forces
tfiS per unit area, and
these are virtual displacements,
delta uiS.
We integrate this product over
the total area of the body.
So this defines the
right-hand side.
On the left-hand side, we have
one quantity here, which is t
tau ij, t once again referring,
of course, to time.
tau is a stress, and ij being
the components of the stress.
This stress is called
the Cauchy stress.
It's a force per unit
area at time t.
And on the left-hand side, we
have also a quantity which is
a virtual strain.
Delta here meaning virtual,
teij meaning the strain.
And it's defined
as shown here.
Now let us look briefly at what
these quantities are.
We have a partial of del ui with
respect to the current
coordinate txj, and we have a
partial of del uj with respect
to the current coordinate txi.
Here I have prepared a view
graph which separates out,
once more, these important
quantities.
And on the top here in red, we
see the virtual displacement
and the virtual strain.
Notice that the virtual strain
here carries a subscript t, a
left subscript t.
This left subscript t means that
it's a strain referred to
the current configuration.
del always meaning virtual,
of course.
And it's important to recognize
the following.
It's important to recognize
that these are the virtual
strains corresponding to these
virtual displacements.
That's the most important
point to recognize.
In green here, we have some
other quantities--
the current volume, the current
surface area of the body.
Current meaning always
at time t.
And here in blue, we see the
externally applied forces.
tfiB being the body forces, the
volume forces, and tfiS
being the surface forces per
unit volume, per unit surface.
These are externally
applied forces.
So we have here quite different
quantities--
namely, virtual quantities
and real quantities.
So let me go back to this view
graph to discuss with you in
more detail what the principle
really tells us.
It tells that the internal
virtual work consisting of the
product of the actual
stresses--
t tau ij, which in
general analysis
are, of course, unknown--
times the virtual strains, which
we impose, this internal
virtual work--
there's an integration over
the whole volume--
must be equal to the external
virtual work.
And the external virtual work,
once again, is given here.
This equation must hold--
and this is an important
point--
for arbitrary variations in
displacement, or arbitrary
virtual displacements that
satisfy the geometric boundary
conditions, that satisfy the
essential boundary conditions,
or you might say, the
displacement boundary
conditions.
In other words, this is an
equation that must hold for
any virtual displacements and
corresponding virtual strains.
Remember, I just said that for
virtual displacement, we
always have corresponding
virtual strains.
This equation must always
hold, provided the
displacements satisfy the
displacement boundary
conditions.
Here we have, once again, the
unknown forces, or stresses, I
should say, forces
per unit area.
Notice these are Cauchy
stresses.
Here we have the word Cauchy.
In an infinitesimal displacement
analysis, we
really only talk about
one kind of stress--
the engineering stress.
In large displacement analysis,
large strain
analysis, we have different
kind of stress measures.
And the stress that I now talk
about here is the Cauchy
stress, which is the force per
unit area at time t, which is,
in other words, an actual
physical stress.
Later on, we will introduce
another kind of stress, a very
important stress measure,
which, however,
is not quite physical.
This one here is a physical
stress, the
force per unit area.
And that is the stress that
you, for example, in a
computer program, would like
to get printed out.
This is the force per unit area
that you would design
your structure with.
This here is, once again,
the virtual strain.
And notice that this strain
is referred to the current
geometry, the coordinate
at time t.
Therefore, stress at time t
times virtual strain at time
t-- that's what we're looking at
here, and that gives us the
total internal virtual
work when we
integrate over the original--
over the current volume,
current, I should say, very
important--
the current volume
of the body.
So if we have a body that
moves through space and
undergoes large displacements,
large rotations, large
strains, then this here is the
quantity of the internal
virtual work with the current
stresses at time t in the
configuration at time t.
Let us look at a schematic
example, because there are so
many important considerations.
Here we have, in a
three-dimensional Cartesian
coordinate frame, denoted with
x1, x2, x3 as coordinate axes,
a body in which we are showing
two material particles.
Notice one of them in the body
itself, in the volume of the
body, rather, and one
on the surface.
The body is here supported,
and this is the
configuration at time 0.
Now this body moves through
a certain amount.
It undergoes large
displacements, large
rotations, large strains,
and takes on the red
configuration here.
Notice that in that red
configuration, we have certain
body forces, which we already
talked about earlier, and
surface forces, that we also
talked about earlier.
Notice that the particles
have now moved to new
configurations, of course,
to new positions.
The surface particle has moved
there, and the particle within
the volume has moved there.
We denote this as tui, the
displacement at time t, or the
displacement from configuration
02,
configuration t, for this
particular particle.
Similarly, here we denote this
displacement as tuiS.
Now the principle of virtual
work says that we will be
imposing on to this red
configuration the
configuration at time t, a
variation in displacement,
which is the virtual
displacement.
And here we see now one such
virtual displacement.
Notice that it is shown by the
blue line for the whole body,
and it's a virtual displacement
from the
configuration at time t.
Notice that the particle, which
was originally here, or
which was at time t here, I
should more precisely say, has
moved to this point in the
virtual displacement.
And similarly, the particle that
was here at time t has
moved to this configuration,
to this point here.
Now, this is one variation.
However, the principle of
virtual work, of course,
states that the left-hand side
must be equal to the
right-hand side--
I think you know now what
I mean by left-
and right-hand sides--
for any variation.
So we have here another
variation.
All such variations, however,
must satisfy the displacement
boundary conditions, and those
displacement boundary
conditions are given
right down here.
Now notice that the particle,
which I looked at earlier
already, has now moved to this
configuration, or in this
variation of displacement.
Similarly, this particle
has moved here.
Now the principle of virtual
work states once again that
for any variation that is
satisfying the displacement
boundary conditions, the
left-hand side, the internal
virtual work, must be equal to
the right-hand side, the
external virtual work.
And these are two variations
that we looked at.
Of course, there are
many, many more.
In fact, we could think of
millions, billions such
variations.
And we will, in finite element
analysis, however, discretize
the whole structure using finite
elements, and then only
allow certain sets
of variations.
Namely, those contained in the
interpolation functions of the
finite elements.
Well, let us now look at
one important point.
Namely that if we were to
integrate the principle of
virtual work by parts, we would
obtain the governing
differential equations of
motion plus the force or
natural boundary conditions,
just like an infinitesimal
displacement analysis.
However, the difference, of
course, is that we have
referred all our static and
kinematic variables now to
time t, to the current
configuration of the body.
Let's look now at an example.
It's a simple example, in
some sense, but it still
illustrates many of the basic
points that I just mentioned.
The example is a truss
stretching
under its own weight.
Here we have the truss
in its original
configuration shown in black.
It has an original length L0.
It's subjected, of course,
to gravity, g.
A typical cross-sectional
area is given here, 0A.
Notice that this bar, under its
own weight, moves down to
the configuration
at time t here.
tA is this cross-sectional
area now.
In other words, this area has
now moved to that area.
The length of the truss, of
course, has changed, and in
fact has changed to tL.
In order to analyze this
problem, we have to make
certain assumptions.
The first assumption is, plane
cross-sections remain plane.
Second assumption--
constant uni-axial stress
on each cross-section.
And then if we make these two
assumptions, then we have a
one-dimensional analysis.
Using these assumptions, we then
obtain directly, from the
general principle of virtual
work, the following.
Here we have, on the left-hand
side, the general left-hand
side of the principle of virtual
work, Cauchy stress,
the virtual strains, integrated
over the current
volume at time t, which then
becomes, on the right-hand
side here, the one stress only,
because we have only one
stress in this bar, the vertical
stress, times the
virtual strain corresponding
to that motion of the bar,
namely, vertically downwards.
And this product is integrated
over the current area at time
t, and of course, the
longitudinal coordinate tdx.
Notice that here we are
integrating over the current
volume, because we have
a tA and a tL here.
The right-hand side becomes,
in this particular case, an
integration over the current
length of the gravity force,
which involves the mass density
at time t, in other
words, the current
mass density.
Notice the mass density,
of course,
changes as the bar extends.
g is the gravity constant.
And here we have the virtual
displacement, area at time t,
and of course the differential
increment tdx.
Once again, we here also
integrate over the
length Lt at time t.
Hence, if we now equate these
two quantities, we directly
obtain what's shown here.
Now it's important to recognize
that in this
equation, these here are the
virtual strains corresponding
to these virtual
displacements.
And once again, we apply
the principle of
course, at time t.
So stresses at time t, meaning
forces per unit area at time
t, area at time t, and so on.
This virtual strain, also used
to describe this quantity, is
given right here.
Notice that here we have
the partial of del u
with respect to tx.
tx, the coordinate at time t.
And this del u is exactly the
del u that we see right there.
Now this principle must hold for
any arbitrary variation in
displacement, any arbitrary
virtual displacement, that
satisfy the displacement
boundary conditions.
And the displacement boundary
condition here, of course, is
simply that the displacement
is 0 at the top of the bar.
If we use, now, integration by
parts on this equation that I
just discussed with you, we
obtain this equation here.
And that equation contains
really two terms,
two parts to it.
First, an integral that is taken
over the length L of the
bar, and then a quantity that
corresponds to the length of
the position 0 and L, tL.
And all of the sum of these
two must be equal to 0.
Since the variation del u is
arbitrary, except, as I
mentioned, right at the top of
the bar, we directly obtain
that this equation must hold,
which is really extracting
this term here from
the integral.
And this, of course,
is the governing
differential equation.
And also, we must have that at
the lower part of the bar,
this force or natural boundary
condition must be satisfied.
Therefore, this is an example
which shows, really, how the
principle of virtual work
contains the basic
differential equations
of equilibrium.
Here it is just one, because we
have only one direction for
the motion.
And also the stress boundary
conditions, the natural or
force stress boundary
conditions.
The finite element application
of the principle of virtual
work proceeds as follows.
Here, once again, virtual
strains, virtual displacements
in the volume of the body and
on the surface of the body.
These are the virtual
quantities.
The actual applied forces,
externally applied forces, are
these blue quantities.
We deliberately chose a
different color to emphasize
that these are real forces,
blue, applied to the body, and
these are virtual
displacements and virtual strains.
The stresses here at time t,
of course, are unknown, and
those we want to calculate.
In the finite element method,
what's shown in this big box,
we interpolate displacements,
virtual displacements.
We calculate from those
interpolations, strains, real
strains, virtual strains.
Via the stress-strain law, we
got stresses, and we will see
in the later lectures that in
fact, what we are arriving at
is a force vector tF and an
external load vector.
Now, this tF here, shown in
green, is a result of this
stress t tau ij.
And it's really the nodal
point force vector that
corresponds to these internal
element stresses, t tau ij.
This R here is a nodal point
force vector that corresponds
to these externally
applied forces.
This del UT, on left-hand side
and on the right-hand side, is
a vector of virtual
displacements, nodal point
displacements, and which, in the
finite element analysis,
we then set equal to the
identity matrix, invoking the
principle of virtual work in
turn for each degree of
freedom, just like we do in
linear elastic analysis.
This becomes the identity
matrix, that becomes the
identity matrix, and the result
is, of course, simply
that tF must be equal to tR.
The procedure that we are
following in this box, of
course, is of much interest
in non-linear analysis.
And what's happening in this box
here, we will be talking
about in some considerable
detail in the later lectures.
But for the moment, let's now
assume that the solution at
time t is known.
Hence the stress at time t,
the volume at time t, et
cetera, are known, and we want
to obtain the solution at time
t plus delta t.
In other words, we want to move
ahead 1 increment in time
delta t and establish the
solution at that time.
The principle of virtual work
applied now at time t plus
delta t in exactly the same way
as we just applied it at
time t results in this
set of equations.
A vector of nodal point forces
that is equivalent to the
current internal element
stresses at time t
plus delta t now.
And these are the nodal point
externally applied forces at
time t plus delta t.
Well, of course, we don't know
t plus delta tF, and for the
solution, we now say that t plus
delta tF is equal to tF,
which we do know, plus
a matrix tK--
we call this as tangent
stiffness matrix--
times del U. If we set this
left-hand side equal to t plus
delta tR, the externally applied
loads, we directly
obtain this equation.
We are putting the unknowns on
the left-hand side, and the
unknowns, of course, are the
incremental displacements.
The tangent stiffness
matrix is known.
It's the matrix corresponding
to the
configuration at time t.
The load vector is known, and
tF is assumed to be known.
Now, this is here an
out-of-balance load vector,
and this set of equations then
result into the solution of an
increment in nodal point
displacements delta U. This
displacement is added to the
displacement at time t to obtain
the displacement at
time t plus delta t.
But--
and here is the big but--
by writing this equation
up here, we had to
linearize the problem.
You see, we are dealing with a
large amount of non-linearity
that can come from the
kinematics, from the material
relationships and so on.
And we had to linearize.
We linearized here about the
configuration at time t to
obtain this term, and this means
that down here in this
equation, we only can have
an approximation sign.
In other words, what we have
calculated are not the exact
increments in nodal point
displacement, but an
approximation to it.
More generally, then, we
repeat that process.
We apply the same process in an
iterative way to obtain a
very accurate solution.
And this is done in
the following way.
On the right-hand side now, we
have a load vector, the one
that we discussed already
before, minus the nodal point
forces corresponding to
time t plus delta t in
iteration i minus 1.
I should say at the beginning
of iteration i, or end of
iteration i minus 1.
This gives us an out-of-balance
load vector.
We're calculating an increment
in displacements, delta Ui.
And that increment in
displacement is added to the
displacements which were
known already.
At the end of iteration i minus
1 corresponding to time
t plus delta t, we knew
these displacements.
We add the increment that we
calculated, and we obtain a
better guess, so to say, for
the current displacement at
time t plus delta t.
Now of course in this iteration
here, we need some
initial conditions, and
the initial conditions
are given down here.
The t plus delta t F 0, in other
words, when i is equal
to 1, then we need t plus delta
t F 0 is given by tF.
The displacement t plus delta t
U0, when i is equal to 1, is
given by tU.
These initial conditions are
used in the iteration here,
and we notice that this set
of equations in the first
iteration, when i is equal to
1, reduces to the equations
that I already discussed
with you with the
previous view graph.
Well, if we look at this
set of equations, we
recognize the following.
Nodal point equilibrium is
satisfied when the equation t
plus delta tR minus t plus
delta tF, i minus
1, is equal to 0.
When the externally applied
loads are equal to the nodal
point forces corresponding to
the stresses at time t plus
delta t, when these two vectors
are equal, or rather,
when R minus F is equal to 0,
then of course we have nodal
point equilibrium.
Compatibility is satisfied
provided a compatible element
mesh is used.
The stress-strain law enters
in the calculation of the
tangent stiffness matrix and the
nodal point force vector
F, which corresponds to the
current stresses at time t
plus delta t, iteration
i minus 1.
Well, we will get back to these
considerations just now.
But most important is to
recognize that we have to
calculate F t plus delta ti
minus 1 very accurately from
the displacements t plus
delta t Ui minus 1.
The general procedure is
depicted on this view graph.
Here we have the displacement
at time t plus delta t ui
minus 1, which give
us strains.
We can directly, via
differentiations of the
displacements, get strains,
which gives us stresses if we
enter here with the appropriate
constitutive relation.
Of course, we have to use the
constitutive relation
corresponding to the problem
that we want to solve.
We get stresses, and the
stresses, then, give us this
nodal point force vector
that I talked about.
Notice that in this relationship
here, we have to
perform an integration, and that
integration is expressed
here, where we obtain the
stresses at time t plus delta
t in iteration i minus 1 by
taking the stresses at time t
and integrating the
stress-strain law times the
incremental strains from time
t to time t plus delta t,
where we use, of course, the
strains at time t, and the
strains at time t plus delta t
corresponding to that iteration.
This step is most important,
because you have to calculate
the F vector correctly so that
when you say that this
equation is satisfied, that
indeed you have obtained the
right configuration for the
finite element mesh that
you're considering.
So it is most important to
calculate the F correctly.
Of course, the tangent stiffness
matrix should also
be calculated appropriately, and
we will talk about that as
well later on.
In all this discussion, I should
point out we assumed
that the nodal point loads are
independent of the structural
deformations.
In other words, they vary only
as a function of time.
Here's a small problem
that schematically
shows what we mean.
The load R is always acting
vertically, never mind how
much this beam has displaced.
And that load variation is shown
here on the graph as a
function of time.
We satisfy the basic
requirements of mechanics if
we perform this finite element
analysis appropriately.
We satisfy the stress-strain law
because we are evaluating
the stresses correctly
corresponding
from the given strains.
We also satisfy the
compatibility requirements
provided we use compatible
elements, and of course we
satisfy the displacement
boundary conditions.
Equilibrium we also satisfy
corresponding to the finite
element nodal point degrees
of freedom.
But there is one important
point.
This means that we only
satisfy global
equilibrium in general.
We satisfy equilibrium locally
only if we use a fine enough
finite element mesh.
In other words, I'd like to
distinguish now between
satisfying global equilibrium
and local equilibrium.
Local equilibrium means that
we want to satisfy the
differential equations of
equilibrium at every
point in the mesh.
And that is only achieved if we
have a large enough finite
elements for the
given problem--
in other words, if our
discretization is fine enough.
A check on whether we are
satisfying local equilibrium
well enough is to look at the
stresses along the boundary
and see whether the
stress boundary
conditions are satisfied.
That is one check.
Another check is to test whether
along boundaries of
the elements, there are small
stress jumps only.
In other words, whether the
stresses from one element to
another element do not
jump too much.
We call that the stress jumping
because as we will
just talk further, when we
calculate the stress at a node
for an element, we get,
of course, one value.
And if at that same node, the
stresses are calculated using
another element, you
would get, in
general, another value.
This stress difference should
not be very large, and of
course, if we have a homogeneous
material, if we
have other conditions satisfied
as well, in other
words, if typically the exact
solution would have a
continuous stress variation,
then the stress jump should be
very small for an accurate
solution.
And this is a good check, an
indication of whether we
indeed have obtained
a valid solution.
Well, I like to now demonstrate
to you some of
these considerations by showing
you the results of two
example analyses.
But it is best if we show these
examples on a different
reel, on a second reel
of this lecture.
Thank you very much.
We just discussed some issues
regarding how equilibrium is
satisfied in a
displacement-based finite
element analysis.
We discussed briefly that global
equilibrium is always
satisfied for any finite
element mesh
that you have selected.
By global equilibrium, we mean
equilibrium at the nodal
points of the finite
element mesh.
However, locally, equilibrium is
only satisfied if the mesh
is fine enough.
And an indication to see whether
a mesh is fine enough
is given, for example, by
whether these stressed
boundary conditions are well
satisfied, and whether there
are no stress jumps
between elements.
I would like now to share with
you experiences relating to
two problems.
These are actually linear
elastic analysis problems that
exemplify how we are looking
at stress jumps in order to
choose an appropriate
finite element mesh.
The first problem is
the analysis of a
plate with a whole.
The plate has certain geometric
dimensions, of
course, and it has also
material data.
The material data are
given right there.
Notice that we also give
material data for an
elastoplastic analysis.
We will not perform now the
We will consider it later.
For the moment, we just need
these two material data.
The| geometric data for the
plate are given here.
Now, this plate with
a hole has a
doubly symmetric structure.
In other words, there are two
symmetry lines, as shown here.
So we only need to look at 1/4
of the plate in the analysis.
Notice that the plate is
subjected to a pulling force
up here and similarly
down here.
The purpose of the analysis is
to accurately determine the
stresses in the plate, and of
course, once again, assuming
that the loads are small enough
to warrant a linear
elastic analysis.
The considerations that are
valid in linear elastic
analysis regarding the choice
of a mesh are of course also
valid in a non-linear analysis,
and we more easily
can discuss them now, just
using a linear elastic
analysis as an example.
Using symmetry, as I pointed out
already, we can just focus
our attention on 1/4
of the plate.
Here is that quarter
Here is the hole.
Notice we have roller boundary
conditions here, roller
boundary conditions there, and
the load is applied up there.
Accuracy considerations in
displacement-based finite
element analysis are that
first of all, of course,
compatibility must
be satisfied.
And that is achieved by
using a compatible
finite element mesh.
The material law must also
be satisfied, and that is
achieved by just using the
appropriate material data.
Of course, in non-linear
analysis, this item needs a
lot more attention, but we are
performing now a linear
elastic analysis, so this is a
very simple condition, and
it's satisfied by simply
selecting the proper Young's
modulus, Poisson's ratio
for the model.
Equilibrium, once again, is
locally only satisfied if we
choose a fine enough mesh.
Otherwise we only approximate
equilibrium locally.
And as I pointed out earlier, we
can observe the equilibrium
error by plotting stress
discontinuities.
Here we have the results
of a two-element
mesh for this problem.
Notice this quarter of the
plate, idealized using just
two 8-node elements.
This is the line z equal to 0,
and we will later on look at
stresses along this line.
This is a line y equal to z.
We will also look at stresses
along this line.
But we will plot the stresses
along this line here as a
function of y.
You should keep that in mind.
In other words, the first stress
quality that we will
see will actually start
somewhere here, because we are
plotting this stress
as a function of y.
The displacements, somewhat
amplified after load
application, are shown here.
Notice the maximum displacement
here, uz, is
0.0285 millimeters.
The maximum stress is at this
point here, 281 MPa,
megapascal.
Well, if we plot the stresses
along the line z equal to 0,
and we're evaluating the
stresses, I should also say,
at the nodal points of the
elements, then we obtain these
values here.
One value there, one value
there, one value there.
And once again, we are plotting
the stresses along
the y-axis, measured along here,
distance, and the stress
magnitude is measured
along here.
Tau zz.
These are nodal point
stresses.
And we simply have drawn a
smooth curve through these
nodal point stresses.
The applied stress, far away
from the hole, is 100 MPa.
If we plot the stresses along
the line y equals z, along
this line here, we notice that
we have a choice of choosing
either the nodal point stresses
from the element
below it or from the
element above it.
Well, the nodal point stresses
from the element below it are
given by the crosses here.
The nodal point stresses from
the element above it--
and notice, these are the nodal
point stresses at these
nodes here are given
by this point.
I should say, actually, that
we are plotting here the
principal stress, the maximum
principal stress.
We only look at one stress.
Of course, you could plot such
curves for all three stress
components, but here we're
looking just at sigma 1 being
the maximum principal stress.
Now there we can see the
stress discontinuity.
We see a stress discontinuity
right at that point.
Let's see once, what does this
stress continuity result from?
Notice that there
is a node here--
and I just like to put
it in one color--
there's a node here coming
from this element.
And there's another node coming
in from that element.
Of course, this red point
corresponds to this mark here.
So this node here gives us a
stress in the stress graph
given by that symbol.
This blue point there is a
node corresponding to the
element with the cross, and
there we get also a stress
value, and that stress value
corresponds to the cross mark
on the graph.
So let's go back to the
graph once more.
Once again, same location,
because this blue node lies
really on top of the red node.
They are put together.
And yet although we're looking
at the same material particle,
we have this stress
discontinuity.
And this stress discontinuity
tells us that the mesh is
really not fine enough.
So we go to a finer mesh.
And here now we have selected
a 64-element mesh.
Once again, 8-node elements,
as shown here, for that
quarter of the plate
with the hole.
Here is the typical
8-node element.
This is the undeformed mesh, and
when we apply the loads,
we obtain this deformed shape.
The maximum stress is now 345
MPa, and the displacement
right at that point here
is 0.0296 millimeter.
Well, we can now once
again plot stresses.
We can plot stresses
along this line--
or I should rather show it here,
along this line, and
along that line, same way
as we have done before.
And let's look at the stresses
along the line z equal to 0.
Of course, y is the coordinate
along which we are plotting
the stresses, and you can see
now here a stress jump, a
stress discontinuity.
This is where two elements
adjoin each other at one node.
Otherwise, we see very little
stress discontinuity.
In fact, too small to
be visible by eye.
If we plot stresses along
the line y equal to z--
and here I should be
more specific.
In fact, we only plot,
once again, the
maximum principal stress.
We find that we get
these curves here.
Now notice that at that
location, we get four distinct
stress values.
The reason being that at this
node, four elements couple
into that node, and that
gives us four stress
values at that node.
If you go further away, we find
that there are very few
or very small stress
discontinuities.
So however, since we have still
one stress discontinuity
there at that one location that
I pointed out, we went
ahead and analyzed an even finer
mesh, 288-element mesh.
This mesh is shown now here,
8-node elements, once again,
in the undeformed shape, and
here in the deformed shape.
Notice that the maximum stress
is now 337 megapascals and the
maximum displacement here
is 0.0296 millimeters.
We can again plot stresses along
this line and along that
diagonal line as a
function of y.
And if we do so, we find that
along the line z equal to 0,
we find for tau zz virtually no
more stress discontinuity.
A nice, smooth stress curve.
And along the line y equal to
z, for the maximum principal
stress, also almost
no discontinuity.
You can see here a slight
discontinuity, but that is
really a very small one that
in engineering analysis, we
generally can live with.
Of course, these stress jump
plots are very useful and very
helpful in identifying
whether a mesh is
actually a good mesh.
However, we should realize
that in order to identify
whether a mesh is really good,
we would have to plot stress
jumps along many lines in the
mesh, and that can, of course,
provide quite some cost.
It also means that we have to
interpret a lot of data.
And one perhaps more convenient
way to look at
whether a mesh is a good mesh
is to plot pressure bands.
We have been lately using this
procedure to identify whether
meshes are good, and I'd like
to just share that latest
experience with you.
You plot bands of constant
pressure, where the pressure
is defined by taking the mean
of the stresses tau xx, tau
yy, and tau zz.
Of course, pressure meaning a
negative sign in front here.
The two-element mesh gives us
this pressure band plot.
Notice that these are bands
of 5 MPa difference.
In other words, here you have a
jump from this point to that
point of 5 MPa, and
once again, from
here to there again.
5 MPa.
These are the pressure
band plots for
the two-element mesh.
Here we have it as the same
kind of plot for the
64-element mesh.
Let's look at this pressure
band plot a
little bit more carefully.
Here we have, as you can see,
again, differences of 5 MPa.
This is a non-dark area,
unshaded area,
provides a band of 5 MPa.
That shaded area provides
a band of 5 MPa.
Now, if we have a good mesh,
then the pressure band should
be continuous.
In other words, this band here
should be continuous, and
there should be no pressure
band break.
Let's look at this one here.
It's nice and continuous,
however, there's a break.
And so there is no continuity
in stresses here, which is
quite simply displayed
by the pressure band
picture shown here.
For a continuous stress field,
we would have no breaks in the
pressure bands.
We have selected here 5 MPa.
Of course, you could also select
1 MPa, and that would
be then a much tighter
criteria.
You could also select 10 MPa.
Of course, then that would be a
very loose criterion, and 5
MPa for this particular problem,
since you can see,
we're getting quite a number
of bands along here, is a
reasonable way to proceed.
If you go to the 288-element
mesh, the pressure band plots
look like this.
Beautifully smooth.
You can see here the smoothness
in the pressure
bands, no discontinuity
at all.
And this shows really that this
mesh certainly satisfies
the criterion of smooth
pressure bands, smooth
pressure variations, over
the whole mesh.
And that is a strong indication
that the stresses
are smooth, and therefore that
the mesh is really an
acceptable mesh.
We see, therefore, that stress
discontinuities are
represented by breaks in
the pressure bands.
As the mesh is refined, of
course, these breaks in the
pressure bands disappear, or
certainly become smoother
until finally they disappear.
The stress state everywhere in
the mesh is represented by one
picture, and that is, of course,
the beauty of this
whole procedure.
If you plot stress jumps, stress
component jumps, then
you have to plot for each
component along all the lines
where elements join
each other, these
components of stresses.
And there is a voluminous amount
of information that is
being generated.
Here we have just one picture
that basically gives us a lot
of information about
the smoothness
of the stress situation.
Of course, the pressure band is
plotted, maybe plotted by a
computer program.
Actual magnitudes of pressure
are not given, but we are not
really interested in seeing
those from these pictures.
What we would like to see are
simply whether the pressure
bands are smooth, and whether,
therefore, the mesh is an
acceptable mesh.
Let's summarize the results.
Here we now performed three
analyses of this plate.
One two-element mesh was used,
a 64-element mesh was used,
and a 288-element
mesh was used.
The number of degrees of
freedom are given here.
Notice that the number of
degrees of freedom goes up
very rapidly as the number
of elements goes up.
The relative cost is given in
this column, and you can see
here that we have normalized
the cost to the cost of the
analysis using the
64-element mesh.
So the two-element mesh is very
cheap, 8% of the cost,
and the 288-element mesh
solution is quite expensive.
The displacement at the top of
the plate is given in this
column, and we notice that with
a 64-element mesh, we
really obtain a very good
displacement prediction.
In fact, there is no
change going to a
larger number of elements.
And the stress concentration
factor, interestingly enough,
increases first and then
slightly decreases.
Notice this is not an
infinite plate--
it's a finite plate, and
therefore you do not get the
value of three, for example,
that you would see in an
infinite plate, for a hole
in an infinite plate.
So the two-element mesh cannot
be used for stress predictions
is certainly a conclusion.
It's not accurate enough.
The 64-element mesh gives
reasonable results for
stresses, and certainly very
accurate results for the
displacements.
The 288-element mesh is probably
overrefined for
linear elastic stress
analysis.
However, for other types of
analysis, for example, an
elastoplastic analysis, if you
want to have very accurate
results, we might want
to use, actually,
this fineness of mesh.
One question that one, of course
might have is, why did
he not use 9-node elements?
We used 8-node elements.
Here we show now a mesh
of 9-node elements.
Notice each of these elements
now is a 9-node element.
Would the solution significantly
improve if we
had used 9-node elements?
In other words, one 9-node
element for each 8-node
element that was used before?
Well, the answer is no.
The solution does not
improve very much.
If you look at this column here,
let's look at the 64
8-node elements solution, in
which case we had 416 degrees
of freedom.
With a 9-node element, we will
have 544 degrees of freedom.
The displacements at the top
are unchanged between the
8-node and 9-node
element results.
The stress concentration
factor is very
little effected here.
Only in the fourth digit,
as a matter of fact.
And the stress jump and pressure
band plot do not
change significantly, either.
Well, the second example that
I'd then like to discuss with
you is the analysis of
a plate with a crack.
We will once again look at
different meshes for this
problem, and we will
also discuss
one additional aspect--
namely that for certain types of
answers that you're looking
for, you actually can use
sometimes very coarse meshes.
Whereas if you're looking for
the answer of a much more
difficult question, of course
you will have to use a much
finer mesh.
Here we have a plate
with a crack.
Notice the plate is subjected
to a pull of 100 MPa right,
and at the left-hand
side, same pull.
The crack is lying
right there.
Notice it's not a a
symmetric crack.
This is a crack tip A, that's
the crack tip B. To model this
plate, we have to really
model half of it.
We have to model half of it,
because the crack is not a
symmetric crack.
The material data for this
problem are given down here.
E, Young's modulus, nu,
Poisson's ratio, Kc is the
fracture toughness.
And here we have the fact that
the thickness of the plate
shall be just 1 centimeter.
It's a plane stress condition
that we're looking at.
And the question that we want
to address here is, will the
crack propagate?
Well, let us look at some
background information.
Since we want to perform a
linear elastic analysis and we
want to apply linear elastic
fracture mechanic theory when
considering whether the crack
will propagate in the plate,
we calculate a stress intensity
factor, and we have
a mode 1 stress condition,
so we calculate K1.
K1 determines the strength of
the 1 over square root r
stress singularity at the crack
tip, r of course being
the radius from the crack tip.
And as very well established
in linear elastic fracture
mechanics, when K1 is
greater than Kc,
the crack will propagate.
Kc is a property of
the material.
The computation of K1 is
performed by this here.
It's equal to the square root
out of E times G. G is
obtained as the partial
differentiation of pi with
respect to a, where pi is a
total potential energy of the
structure, and a is the area
of the crack surface.
G is known as the energy release
rate for the crack.
This is quite well established,
and what we want
to do, of course, in the finite
element analysis, is to
calculate this G value.
The question is, how
do we do that?
Well, in this finite element
analysis, each crack is
represented by a node.
And if you look at a cut through
the plate where this
is here the crack, we have
this here as the node
at the crack tip.
This node in the finite element
analysis is, so to
say, moved forward a
differential amount, so that
the change in crack
area is given via
this little bit here.
Now that the original crack tip
location is here, the new
crack tip location
is right there.
Then we can, in this process,
evaluate del pi over del a as
del pi del l times
1/t, where t is a
thickness of that plate.
Of course, this here is only
conceptually being done, that
we're actually moving
the crack.
What we're really doing is the
differentiation of del pi with
respect to l, where l is the
length of the crack and del l
is the differentiation of l
into this direction here.
The quantities del pi del l may
be efficiently calculated
by an algorithm that we have
just recently been publishing.
Of course, there are different
algorithms available as well,
but we would like to use this
procedure to calculate
data pi over l.
And you can look up how
it's being done in
this particular paper.
Let's look at the results.
Finite element analyses have
been performed using a
17-element mesh, and this
is the mesh here.
We call this a coarse mesh.
Notice the crack
is right there.
Notice that we have only two
elements above the crack, to
the boundary of the plate, and
we have here once again also
only two elements below it.
Notice that these nodes around
the crack tip B have been
moved to the quarter point.
And similarly, they've been
moved here to the quarter
point, meaning that this node is
not at the midpoint of this
element side, but at the
quarter point of
that element side.
And similarly for the other
nodes around the crack tips.
If we look at the results, the
stress results, maybe plus the
stresses on the line of
symmetry, we find that tau yy
varies as shown here, then of
course increases very rapidly
near the crack.
This is where the crack is.
Increases very rapidly, then
drops down to very close to 0.
Of course, it should
be 0 right in here.
And here we have, coming from
the other side to crack tip A,
this very rapid variation
in stresses.
These are the stresses tau yy.
If you look at the pressure
band plot--
I introduced you to those
kinds of plots
in the earlier example--
we find that the pressure
jumps are really
larger than five MPa.
For example, you can see it
right here, you can see it
right there, you can
see it right there.
So it's a coarse mesh, and
certainly the stresses are not
very well represented,
not very well picked
up with this mesh.
However, if we look at the
stress intensity factors that
we wanted to estimate in this
analysis, because they will
tell us whether the crack will
propagate or not, we find that
for the stress intensity
factors, for example, KA, we
get an excellent solution.
For KB, the solution is not
as good, but perhaps still
acceptable.
We now go to a finer mesh,
a much finer mesh.
128 elements are used
in this mesh.
And we can see once again
here, 1/2 the plate.
Here is point A, crack tip A.
Here is point B, crack tip B.
Notice the crack lies
in between.
And we will be plotting stresses
along this line.
This is a line of symmetry here,
and we will plot tau yy,
which is the stress across
here, as a function of z.
But let's first look a little
bit closer at the mesh.
If we look at one detail closer
to the crack tip A, we
see this is the mesh that we
use, and we can go still
further and show the elements
just around the crack tip,
right A. Here is A. Notice
that we use triangular
elements, these are
isoparametric degenerate
elements, and that we have
moved, once again, the nodal
points from the midpoint
to the quarter point.
Because we know that if we do
so, we are generating in the
finite element the 1 over square
root r singularity that
we would like to have in the
analysis, because we know that
the stresses vary as
a function of 1
over square root r.
So it's of benefit to shift
the nodes to the quarter
points, as was done
in this example.
Now we look here at
the stresses.
Stresses tau yy, as I pointed
out, is a function of z.
And you can see here a stress
that very rapidly grows, then
on the other side comes down
to practically 0 in the
cracked area, and on the other
side, coming again now from
the right here, a stress that
varies very rapidly up close
to tip A.
We also can see here that
the stress variations
are nice and smooth.
Of course, that indicates to us
that the mesh is really a
good mesh, but we can
also look at our
pressure bands again.
We find that the pressure jumps
are quite small if we go
not too close to
the crack tip.
In other words, here we have
some pressure band variation,
some pressure band breaks, but
we have still quite smooth
bands that tell us that the
mesh is quite fine.
If we go very close to the crack
tip A, then we find that
the pressure jumps are, of
course, large right here.
You can see here breaks
in the pressure bend.
Right here, for example, a
typical example, if you look
very closely here, there's
a black band coming
into a white band.
So there's clearly a break
in the pressure band.
So here, then, in this area,
the stresses are not
continuous, and would also not
be very accurately predicted.
However, we know that our scheme
of calculating the
stress intensity factor works
for even a coarser mesh, and
for this fine mesh, we've got
indeed excellent results, as
you can see for KA and for KB.
Both are very well predicted.
The point of this analysis is
really that the degree off
refinement needed in a mesh
depends on what kind of
question you have, what kind of
problem you're solving, and
what kind of question
you're asking.
If you're only interested in
predicting displacements
accurately, a coarse
mesh may do.
If you want to calculate stress
intensity factors, also
a coarse mesh may do.
If you want to calculate lowest
natural frequencies,
associate mode shapes in a
dynamic analysis, once again,
a coarse mesh might
very well do.
However, if you want to
calculate stresses very
accurately, then you may
need a fine mesh.
And in general non-linear
analysis, we need accurate
stresses, because the stresses
influence the material
relationship that has to be
used as we go through the
incremental solution.
And therefore, frequently we
need, in non-linear analysis,
a finer mesh than what would do
well in a linear analysis.
So we should keep that in mind,
that in fact what might
be a sufficiently fine mesh in
linear elastic analysis may
not be sufficiently fine in
a non-linear elastoplastic
geometrically non-linear
analysis.
Of course, how fine the mesh
has to be in a general
non-linear analysis depends very
much on many criteria,
criteria that we will still
discuss in the next lectures
of this course.
But I hope this gave you a bit
of an overview of what are
some important considerations
in linear as well as
non-linear analysis.
Thank you for your attention.